[Music]
thanks for joining us at the playstation
competition center for another video on
soul calibur six i'm mark matt and along
with rip we're going to get into the
lethal hit mechanic of soul calibur 6.
and this is a little bit of a tricky
topic to cover because it's so character
specific
but even just knowing what a lethal it
is is going to help you improve your
soul caliber skills
lethal hits are regular moves that get
powered up if they fulfill a unique
condition
let's start with a simple example that's
universal to every single character the
brake attack
normally you use these attacks to do
some damage to the opponent's guard and
they beat guard himself
these are mechanics that we've talked
about in other videos what happens if
someone tries to beat a guard impact
with your brake attack
you're rewarded with a lethal hit that
often leads to more damaging results
if we go to the move list and look at
the lethal hit attacks tab we can see
that our brake attack triggers a lethal
hit
if you counter a guard impact each
character has a large assortment of
moves that can earn lethal hit
properties
and the conditions you need to meet them
will vary wildly between the characters
let's take a look at some achilles
tweezers some of them are designed to
counter certain moves
for example backless vertical will be a
lethal if you hit someone after
successful guard impact
and his running vertical attack will be
illegal if you hit someone who with an
attack
this one is useful because as we explain
in our video on attacks
you can make vertical attacks with as
you sights up against them therefore
this gives you an increased reward for
using the move for its intended strategy
but there are some wacky leaflet
conditions too killik's backless
horizontal is a decent low attack that
doesn't do much damage
but if he hits with four of them the
fourth one leads to hits for a combo
or how about his down forward plus b
attack that launches the opponent in the
air
normally a useful move for starting
comes already but it will become a
lethal hit if you activate a soul charge
sometime during the previous round
maybe one of the most unique lethal hit
conditions is ivy's down forward k
which is a lethal hit versus only male
characters
it's important to mention that you
shouldn't have to feel obligated to
learn every single legal hit for your
character
and especially not every single legal
hit in the game there's just way too
many
instead you should focus on ones that
seem practical for your gameplay
exactly like for calyx's example he's
got this low attack on the fourth hit
it's going to act to be a lethal so this
might be a good low attack
for you to look for also if you have
some other legally conditions to look
for you might want to look for stuff
that's like
legal hits on a whipped attack or lethal
hits on a guard impact here
these kind of things are going to be the
ones that are most useful to find an
actual matchup
the rest of you can kind of figure out
over time as you have more experience
that'll do it for this episode this
tutorial was made in partnership with
the playstation competition center team
you can sign up for their open series
competitions on compete.playstation.com
subscribe to the bne esports channel for
more tutorials and soul calibur 6
content